oh okay you know what I just wanted  something easy like eat my vegetables  this on why yeah she's actually right  that's a difficult resolution to  manifest as the other guy would say it's  actually a horrible resolution it's  basically impossible like you can't  decide that my New Year's resolution is  I'm going to love myself more you can  sit around all day thinking about  yourself and thinking about how you feel  about yourself and it just becomes this  self-cannibalizing cycle where you're  circling around the drain you could do  that but you're not going to be able to  conjure this love for yourself that  you're trying to loving yourself I'm not  saying that you shouldn't love yourself  We Are All Made in the image of God and  so for that reason we should love  ourselves we should accept ourselves  that's true think of it more of as a  byproduct of a healthy life